this is a talk that's sort of based on
some of the work that our team has done
over the last year we took ownership of
a system of flat iron that is has been
around for a while it's very critical
realized there were a bunch of
challenges and getting it to do the
things we wanted to do and came up with
a plan to get to a happy interstate so
we're gonna talk about what happened
during the process well so as Sam said
we are engineers at flatterin health
I've been at flattering for about three
and a half years Marcus has been there
for about - pretty much something like
that we've both been on a variety of
different things during our ten-year
flat iron and now we work together on
the team that was responsible for
building data tooling so our team builds
tools and libraries that are used by
other engineers at Flatiron to work with
the data that we are generating so in
the beginning as I mentioned we
inherited a system that had been around
at flattering for a while so it's
flattering primary data pipeline
application system it was written in the
early days of the company for context
the company is about six I want to say
little over six years old maybe seven
time flies who knows and it's really
it's used as a system through which we
write our data products so a flatiron
equals a lot of their products which we
sell during their leaders at the company
we realized that we needed a system that
could do a variety of different things
which we'll cover there was nothing
really out there that met all the needs
so like engineers everywhere we said
let's build it ourselves so when we
created the team that we're on now a
data tooling about a year and a half ago
we sort of got voluntold
to own this magnificent system as often
happens and so we as we took ownership
of it we had to do a lot of discovery to
realize okay so now we own this thing
which is very important what does that
really mean for us as engineers on this
team so what have you adopted yeah so as
I'm
it's sort of a very core system too
flattering it's used for building most
if not all the datasets that we as a
company generated himself which means
it's extremely mission-critical it's
also extremely stable which is to say
that the system was authored as I
mentioned during the early days there's
been obviously a lot of development
that's happened over the years but for
the most part it's not something that
you know has brainy changes all the time
the changes that it has are very minimal
there's a few engineers of the company
who really understand it and make
changes to it but by and large it's a
system that since it was authored has
been more or less in a very good stable
State it's made up of a lot of dark
magic voodoo let's say so the innards
are a very complicated mishmash of Bosch
make Python see all the fun technologies
of course everyone is super familiar
with all the time right and as I said so
if you are working within flutter you're
probably going to use the system if
you're on our research of the company
which builds data products and as you
get started you realize that really the
only way that you're really going to
learn the system is by working on the
system it's super critical but hey that
doesn't mean you have gray dots around
it right so people have developed
patterns and workflows we have
onboarding sessions which have you
follow example pipelines that you can
build to sort of understand the system
here and there but really it's not a
great experience and typically engineers
who start working on it
spend let's say roughly about a quarter
before they feel like I kind of
understand what's going on here and I
can have a mental model of what I'm
about to do with a change which is still
wrong so yeah and also as I mentioned it
supercritical which means that there's a
lot of people who use it which means
there's a lot of people who want things
from it that are not in it right now
right it's a system that's used by
hundreds of engineers it's not gonna be
perfect for everyone so there's a lot of
feature requests that are always
outstanding in it there's people who
make contribution
to it here and there and it also means
that those people are very protective of
the code so if you have spent a long
time understanding a very complicated
system and feeling like you've climbed
that summit and someone wants to come in
and sort of change it up underneath you
you were probably going to react to it
in a not happy way because you feel like
I put in the effort to do this you
should too
so if you're gonna make changes to it I
have opinions as all the case it's very
black box the engineers who understand
it I've devoted many many hours getting
to that point and unfortunately none of
those engineers are on the team that
took ownership of the system once you
know great decisions all around so it's
it's use of power all for a beta stuff
which means at this point as the company
has grown there's let's say roughly tens
of thousands of files that are built
within this ecosystem so it's not
something that is trivial to sort of
iterate on or change and as I mentioned
when we built it we built it because
there was really nothing that did all
things that we needed to do I'll specify
some of the things just for contact so
it's it's used for versioning
reproducibility of data so if you're
building a dataset as a healthcare
company it's very important for us to be
able to prove that whatever data we
built was built in a way where you can
look at the snapshot of the data it
subsequently leads into having
provenance around the data that you're
working with in building it's a very
flexible system in that you can write
your pipelines in really any language so
long as you support the interface that
is used for building the data sets so
everything comes in as CSV everything
goes out as a CSV we're trying to change
that but let's get into that later
and it's the workflow orchestration
system as well so you write a bunch of
your notes for your pipeline and then
this thing can understand how to build
your dab and run it for you as well so
it does a variety of different things
and now there's tools on the market that
are very mature that do some if not all
the things but for our needs when we
started noting met all the check boxes
so here we are cool so now you want the
system
it's very critical you kind of
understand what you've gotten yourself
into where do we go from here so as you
start to talk about all right I own the
system I want to make changes to it you
first have to figure out what are the
things that you want to be doing and
should you even do anything at all
so flatterin has a bunch of values which
are very important for us they're taught
to every new employee who starts and
people are sort of encouraged to espouse
them during their day to day lives and
one of those values is start with why if
you're about to do something or someone
else is about to do something it's a
good idea to ask all right why should we
do this why is this important why why
are we spending this time manpower money
to do whatever you're proposing that we
should do so you've taken ownership of a
legacy system now should you even do a
migration to make it modern right what
what would you gain if you did this and
there's two parts of that right what do
you again is a maintainer and what do
people gain as users what what is the
onus for making any changes to the
supposedly stable system if it's lazy
right is it gonna make the lives of
people who are maintaining it easier are
people going to start seeing some new
capabilities that didn't exist in the
system or is it going to be bells and
whistles that you're planning and adding
which would require say quarters of your
time to do but people don't really care
about it or it doesn't really unlock any
new business capabilities assuming you
figure out all of those questions and
you come up with answers that lead you
down the path of we need to do something
with the system you have to figure out
all right so how do we want to get to
whatever the future looks like there's
always a few different options that you
can take right you can always build or
buy so you have a system there's things
you wanted to do maybe as we discuss
right when we started there was nothing
on the market that did all the things
that we wanted to do that was six seven
years ago maybe that's
- anymore so as they're about to embark
on maybe making changes to a very legacy
system maybe it's a good time to
re-evaluate is there even a point in us
doing anything do we rebuild it from
scratch do we abandon the system all
together and decide what we want the
good end state to look like and just
spend the time building it from scratch
so that we don't have to deal deal with
understanding a bunch of legacy code and
doing the work to bring into modern the
state instead of just starting from
clean blank new state where you can
write PI 3/8 code from scratch and not
have to deal with type of 7 or god
forbid 2 6 or do you not build it at all
and you just go out into the market pay
someone a bunch of money buy something
that they've already built and make it
someone else's problem right also a
perfectly viable path it might be
cheaper for the organization to just pay
someone money to get a system and get
vendor support from it as well instead
of spending time and engineering efforts
into building something yourself that
really at best replicates something
that's already community standard yeah
so let's say you don't do that let's say
you go down the path of modernizing your
system so you're gonna put in a lot of
effort and give a tender loving care to
to make it into a modern system we'll
talk more about that as we get along
because as you mayor that's kind of the
point of this talk or you do nothing at
all right as we said it's stable it
meets the needs of most of the people
who are working for it for your company
it does what it was intended to do and
people are still able to develop and
provide value to the business from it
maybe you shouldn't do anything at all
right one of the things that we taught
or found useful to ask was great let's
say we don't want to do anything would
we be happy as maintainer x' of the
system if we did nothing would it be
something that would then lead engineers
on the team to burnout as they're trying
to fight with legacy code as random bugs
happen here there are people still going
to enjoy working on the system or are
they going to
what am I doing here what is the point
of me being on this team maintaining the
system that's not really under my
control to change maybe I should be
doing something else with my time all
together cool so we we evaluated our
options when we said we're gonna
modernize this thing we're gonna we're
gonna change what it looks like
great so as you start doing that you
have to paint the picture of what what
are you trying to accomplish here right
so the first thing you should figure out
is what are people doing with the system
that you've just taken ownership of
right there's always the intended use
case for system developers right
something say alright this is the
problem that I'm trying to solve with
this thing if you have this problem
great come along and do this over time
users always find very creative ways to
do things that engineers never think of
engineers find really creative ways to
do things engineers ever think of and
maybe the actual pattern that is being
followed by your users is not what was
intended by the developers and you come
and take ownership of the system you
read through it you understand all right
this thing is meant to solve use cases a
B and C one of these people who are
doing X Y & Z no I'm not gonna support
that I'm gonna cut you off right there
great now you have a bunch of very
unhappy users who are not going to trust
you whenever you make any changes and
I'm just gonna go and find something
else because you know what are you doing
not supporting listening
you can't just point fingers and say
this system was not intended to do this
if for the past several years people
have been doing something else
altogether at some point that is the
intended purpose of your system it
doesn't matter what the original intent
or what the works bringing in a document
nothing is set in stone right so
patching hacks that provide
functionality to users is never a good
idea you have to have the empathy for
your users to say alright maybe this was
not intended to be the thing that you
should do but you're doing it now it's a
thing that we're gonna have to support
so you figure that out great now figure
out what do you want the end state to
look like you modernize the system at
what point do you say it's modern it's
done this is what what I think the
system needs to be at for me to be happy
owning it so a few different things that
are going to if it's there are
once and once the system is modernized
how does that affect the iteration speed
for maintainer Ziff I want to make a
change into the system how much effort
do I have to put in to accomplish
something very trivial if I'm changing a
one-line thing does that mean I have to
spend two weeks of my time before I can
release it and know that it works or can
I do it faster and have a tighter for
for making changes you made a change
great how do you validate that the
change works do you have a good eco
system for testing and knowing that your
system is actually stable or is it
deployed in production and see who comes
and yells at me what does a release not
saying we don't do that but you know
some people might I don't know how much
effort does it take for new people to
get started with your system so as I
mentioned it's a lot of blood sweat and
tears for you to feel like a power user
of the system that's not a great pattern
right you don't want people to feel like
they have to climb a mountain before
they can do anything with your system
not everyone needs to be a hardcore
athlete in order to participate in in
the world at your bullying and also as
you make changes and reach this end
state are you going to leave behind a
lot of people who are the power users of
your system you will often discover that
power users are great and that they know
a lot of things about the system they're
also more often than not pretty jaded
about the system because they fought
with it for years and one of the things
that you'll want to do is gain their
trust you want them to feel good about
you owning the system especially if you
are not yourself a power user of the
system as well as I as was our case so
you want to make sure whatever you are
proposing is the end state has everyone
on board the the people who are using
this day and night and the people who
are going to be using this as they join
the company or join the organization and
of course walk before you can jump and
jump before you leap so you you define
the end state you're not going to go out
tomorrow and rip the rug out from
underneath everyone and say great and in
one sprint we're gonna change this
entire system altogether that's not
gonna work for a number of reasons
obviously so one good thing to do is
break out your project at that point
into high-level milestones as what does
the modernization mean at each stage
within those milestones you should have
very small iterative chunks that you can
easily test so that you know with
confidence as you're progressing that
things are moving in the right direction
and again define the end state right
define when it's done so for that you
need to figure out what actually matters
for me to say I'm done what are the
things that need to exist in this end
state for me to be happy what what parts
of the system do you keep what do you
remove we'll get into that
and again just have good testing
throughout the process as you go along
so yeah you want to paint a picture and
you have to do it over an existing
canvas if someone else has already
painted a potentially beautiful or not
picture and that's the canvas that
you're working with so probably a good
idea to not waste good parts right there
might be really solid foundation for the
system and you don't really need to
fight with that so you should figure out
what are the parts that are good to keep
versus what are the parts that don't
belong at all so don't belong it all
might be this is not a good pattern for
the code to follow or this makes my life
harder as a developer it might also be
that there's now actually dead code in
your system that no one is using and
that code might be very difficult for
you to maintain or migrate so before you
start fighting with all the parts of the
system figure out one of the parts that
people actually care about what's being
used versus something that was developed
years ago and is completely irrelevant
now but would require a lot of time for
you to take ownership and change and
also you have to do this without
spilling any paint all over the floor
which is to say that the system still
has to work in production all the while
you're making changes people are going
to be using it day in and day out and
they're not going to wait for you to say
I'm gonna kill this and bring it up
later once we're more stable right cool
so with that we'll talk about the work
that we did for automating a lot of the
different parts of the puzzle yeah so
I'm gonna hand it over and Marcus will
talk about some of the work that we did
with respect to figuring out what parts
required people on what parts don't so
the system that we that we inherited
also had very little in the way of
several automatic testing so the first
thing we did was we said okay well this
thing runs in production production is a
test it's a bad test but it is a test so
it's like what's the minimal piece of a
piece of production that I can harvest
so that I can build a representative
sample of how the system works and then
just run this thing all the time so you
can sort of have a good estimate of like
I've changed the thing it hasn't broken
it's maybe fine and that way you can
start building up a set of a set of sort
of faithful reasonably good unit tests
fairly quickly by basically just running
real production workloads on it just in
a way that it doesn't target actual Pro
that it doesn't actually produce real
production data so it's like harvest
what you have in production it's
extremely useful the stuff runs already
and you can probably talk to people and
finally try to actually use it use case
patterns of how the stuff works so and
then by doing so you will you will also
gain some empathy for your users like
how the hell they're using the system
and your guys understand why things are
the way they are so we did this so we
build our big sort of smoke test system
it runs all the time cool we're happy
now except we're not there's loads of
code that's like really outdated there
and as we mentioned before this loss of
it so how do you do this you can't do
this yourself so we stood on a lot on a
lot of sort of open source technologies
to come to can do large-scale sort of
code refactorings so find all of these
tools that already exist well that will
modernize code and so do things we have
like large systems that we just run a
lot lots of just standard rip crepin and
grep over over code bases you just move
pieces around and sort of change them
and make them more modern
and in that way you can automatically
run these things as the main line of the
code which is stolen production
progresses so you can sort of I make all
these changes to my code but it doesn't
have to be simultaneous you will find
that if you have lots of code here just
working in a get side branch doesn't
really work you have to be able to sort
of continuously reapply a lot of the
stuff that you're doing up until you get
to a point where you're actually at
something that can actually run a lot of
these test Suites and things like that
in it sort of semi post modernized State
so we used a lot of a lot of standard
things so pipe modernized and pie
upgrade and then at some point you know
you hit an edge so now you need to start
building your own tool store to help
yourself automate this this migration
we're a pretty small team so when we
started this it was basically us there's
slightly more now but it's still not a
huge it's like it's not a huge team so
going through like tens of thousands of
lines of code it's just or tens of
thousands of files of code just not
gonna happen so so we build it we built
a little thing which we don't have a
great name for which we call structural
refactoring so you can basically write a
couple of couple of tools that can sort
of automatically turn something like
this which is old-style pandas into
slightly less old-style pandas and the
way we've we've structured this is you
can basically is you can decompose all
Python code into an ast and then you can
do sort of pattern matching on this code
and you can find bits and you can move
them forward so this is an example of
what one of these things looks like so
it's got a sort of a little pattern you
can find it and you can find this thing
and then you've got a you've got a
replacer and you can change things out
so we're working on on open sourcing
this and we think this would be is a
generally useful tool for the community
to use in sort of helping helping them
to maintain both sort of external
packages as well as internal libraries
that sort of move forward rapidly so we
built it on top of like a lot of
pre-existing grey tech so
we didn't really write a lot of this we
just stood on the shoulders of giants
and so with a little bit of googling you
can find a lot of really great stuff
that you can just mostly so-so cobble
together into a great into a really
great little tool so and as a last
resort it's like you know edge cases are
everywhere right so we've done all this
automation so that we can sort of move
large hunks of the code forward
automatically in a in a very structured
way but there's always that special case
this is this there's that thing that
works and you know you need to make the
value of the assessment of look this
thing is strange there's like three of
them should I go and pull the tool to
automatically move them or do I just fix
them by hand
right so it's the standard Python ethos
of special cases it's like they're not
special enough to break the rules but
let's be practical about it so there's
always the allure that's like I'm
modernizing this thing I can fix it
right like there's this awful thing
there you can just see it and you've got
the design in your head and you it's
like this will be great like don't just
just step back a bit look at the
problems like there's a lot of other
stuff that you have to get done first
and you know you you don't at this point
you don't even necessarily know it's
like what's actually running so there's
a lot more pieces that you can rather
bow to to maintain the stability of your
system so you need to be comfortable in
this in this process of actually
treating portions of your system as a
black box which is a very very
uncomfortable situation for a developer
to be in especially when you can see the
code but it's not easy software so
treating it as a black box and sayings
like well I know what goes in and I have
these test Suites and I wouldn't know
what comes out so just both more of
those and then you can start
understanding a lot more behavior of
yours
whilst you internally both confidence
and understanding and sort of lifting
the veil over your black box so
instrument everything so the more the
more you know about the runtime behavior
of your system and how things flow and
the states of them the more informed
you're going to be and the the better
result you're ultimately going to have
in your new world and you can keep that
instrumentation because your users are
going to use this in the future
yeah so again very important thing you
have to remember your users and but he
goes both ways which is to say that
users up panes so to maintain errs and
you cannot just set the maintainer look
at the code and try to think of what
will make my life easier the end goal
has to be will make the system usable
for everyone involved right so you have
to think about what what do people need
from this and what do I need from this
which is to say if you're gonna propose
telling your users I'm not going to
develop any new features that you want
from the system for say six months
because I'm gonna spend the time gutting
the Foundation's that's all well and
good but then at some point you have to
pay back that debt that you're taking on
from them right which is what we had to
do we when we take ownership of the
system we started talking to our
stakeholders and we realize that people
have literal spreadsheets where they
ranked features that they want as
critical high low whatever and they gave
it to us and said this is what we need
for for our side of the business this is
the timeline and this is why it's really
important please make this happen
and we looked at it and we realized
there's literally no way that we can
make these changes in any sort of way
that will make us feel like we can do
this safely without breaking everything
with every comment that we make so at
some point we made the decision of
talking to our users and telling them
we're sorry you will see nothing from us
that you care about for the next six six
months but we promise that after that
we'll give you a lot of the things that
you want much faster than we can now as
you can imagine they were not super
thrilled about
you did get some amount of pushback but
in the end we we stood firm and we said
you have to understand what life is like
on this side of the fence as well and we
we can promise you that you will see the
rewards if not immediately then over
time but as you do that you have to give
them that end deadline of this is by
when I can confidently say that we will
pivot to making the future improvements
that you want from us
you cannot just tell them we need to
make the system modern we don't know how
long it's gonna take but we'll tell you
when we're done because people are just
gonna at some point stop caring and stop
listening to you and either they'll lose
faith in the system or they lose faith
and you as developers and maybe the
business will make a decision that you
guys are not the best people to be
owning this piece of tech maybe we'll
hand it off to someone else so as you do
this even though you can tell them we're
not going to make the changes that you
want you still have to kind of give them
a little something a long way so pick
tiny improvements that you can make in
the system safely as you do your
large-scale migrations so that you can
at least make their lives iteratively
better if not exponentially better so
welcome to the world tomorrow right once
you're done once the system is
modernized now you have to pay back that
debt as I mentioned so as you think of
what are the features that I can build
out pick things that are super impactful
big things that most people will see
benefit from or some people will see
really exponential benefits from no big
tiny features for future improvements
that you feel like you can make safely
because you kind of understand that part
of the system you have to then
prioritize the needs of your users even
if it means going to some of those block
boxes a little bit hopefully you let go
enough of an ecosystem where you have
some good testing and visibility to know
that the changes you're making you're
safe at that point but you have to think
things that people will look at as the
end result and go all right that was
worth my time and trusting you and you
got to open the gates you have to let
people contribute to that system as well
you will find that probably those our
users have been making more changes than
anyone
system and they're probably still gonna
want to do that and you can't just say
alright we've now changed what the
system looks like we are the weird
maintainer x' you can't make changes
anymore a better approach is figure out
what the SLA for a contribution looks
like so define that up front and then
tell users this is the new pattern that
we have to follow regardless of the fact
that you might have made a hundred
commits into this repository over the
last six months now there's this new
world and this is a pattern if you
disagree with it let's talk about what
parts you disagree with but this is now
a contribution workflow that has to be
followed for any new changes that you
want to interview so that you can feel
good as maintainer x' about taking on
responsibility and users can still feel
like I can make my life better and don't
have to wait for you to prioritize a
feature that I want from the system and
don't rinse and repeat which is to say
great you spend this time modernizing
the system do not rest on your laurels
and say alright this is now fine no one
needs to worry about the system let's
move on to building the next week next
great piece of path right you have to
make sure that once you bring it up to
parity you actually maintain it
otherwise really in pipe native 20 22
other people from plethora are gonna be
standing here and telling you about the
great work they did in migrating this
lazy system so with that we will hand it
over to you to ask any questions
[Applause]
we're not I'm afraid I am wondering the
fact that this is a data pipeline the
internal tool
what makes that does that make it more
complicated less complicated an avid of
their internal tooling I was wondering
if you could talk about a little bit
about sort of the idiosyncracies of data
related software cool concern natural
yeah so really it's not so much about
the data part it is more about the fact
that we are kind of like a platform team
right which means that the users of our
system are really for the most part most
the engineering within the company which
means that there's a lot of very diverse
use cases so any changes that you want
to make it has to kind of be evaluated
against potentially the needs of
pondering 50 to one or different
engineers so the biggest challenge
really was what changes can we make that
some people are not going to veto
immediately because it's just so against
our use case that we we can make it
safely or we can't do it without
abandoning a chunk of the business for
us that's always like the biggest
question as as the team that sits in the
middle at the base layer what can we do
with a lot topple the house that's built
on top of this yeah the the other part
is that a lot of sort of a lot of
pipelines of data pipelines sort of code
in various in various enterprises
frequently has relatively poor to no
testing so so the which is true of most
code unfortunately but so the the part
that makes it makes it a lot more sort
of tricky is that your your output of
knowing that things are still correct
it's a little bit more complicated than
just does it run it's does it still
produce the actual correct
the actual correct data set is an output
so this
but more validation that needs to go
into that of so comparing prior with
prior with current and etc so there's
some sort of temporal aspects of this
that you need to take take into account
as well the question was can we give an
example in use case of the system yeah
so I guess in what context wouldn't it
it would an example be helpful
it's just something about how the system
works or something about what when he
felt was legacy and you get it in
modernizing so there as I mentioned it's
used to build all of our data products
so what that really means is that people
write different parts of the ETL
pipeline so really everything from
extract this data from the source to
apply this business logic using Python
or sequel or whatever else to put this
data in this location for me to use to
run a different pipeline on top of it so
I mean sure so so I fly down health we
do a lot of work with with medical data
because we we work with we work very
heavily with the HR data so these
datasets are sensitive some of them are
large they're all generally fairly
complicated so a lot of lot of what the
of what our analysts and sort of
engineers are very skilled at is being
able to sort of understand a lot of
medical value of data and and and really
know the the J the true sort of like
business and and they they bring a lot
of sort of domain expertise so they so
they tend to work in a lot of these sort
of smallish files that sort of that know
how to like transform and extend and
some normalize say a drug name of some
a drug has numerous names because the
medical space is weird you'd like to
build a data set that has normalized all
of these things to base ingredients okay
right so so that pipeline is is
important so you've now taken a list of
say all the drugs that a patient has
given you've normalized them into base
components that pipe the output of that
pipeline there is then used by loads of
other downstream things so yeah it's
published as a thing and then everything
and then downstream pieces can use this
so obviously you need to be very careful
when these pipelines get very deep and
in our cases our pipelines are extremely
deep and lots of these pipelines are
fairly small individually but the
aggregate behavior of them becomes very
complex right I mean as you can expect
there's hundreds of different thousands
of different pipelines most of them use
some common base notes that run across
all of them so as you're making changes
to how the system generates output any
changes that you make to a file could
potentially affect thousands of other
things that you're building downstream
so yes so the question was are we making
changes to the system that is running
the pipeline's or the pipeline's
themselves the answer is a little bit of
both for the most part we own the system
that runs the pipeline's but two are so
coupled you can't really draw a clean
line across the board so what I really
ended up meaning was we wanted to change
a lot of the parts of how things are
being run but also we needed to provide
users a path to get to the new world of
what their pipelines need to look like
to play nice with the system so a lot of
the work that we ended up doing with the
ASU refactor part that mario's talked
about ran over people's pipeline code
and brought their code up to a new
modern standard yes
I was just wondering you guys said you
inherited this and had it really worked
I'm in the similar situation do you guys
have to act it with my product support
while you're doing all of this yep yes
yes so the decision of us owning it was
kind of like a weird one in a sense
because obviously you probably don't
want people who have not really work
with the system very deeply to take
ownership but at the same time the team
was centered around solving problems of
data tooling at the company you can't
kind of have a team that does that
without having to own the thing that
does most of the data tooling of the
company so yes we still have to provide
support for it as we went along for
thankfully at that time we did have a
product manager on the team who used to
be data data insects engineer who was
one of the power users of the system so
when questions came up on how do I guess
in the system and the two of us looked
at each other and said he kind of
answered that but yes there were
occasionally times when we basically
into digging to things ourselves to be
able to answer questions for people who
were maybe not as familiar with it yes
and no yes in that we actually held
office hours regularly for people to
come to us for questions with the system
and before we started this giant
refactor we spent about three to six
months improving the documentation
around it so we took all the existing
dogs that were there every kind of clean
them all up to get rid of the ones that
didn't make sense anymore roads in new
ones just to clarify some basic
workflows and then partnered with other
years on your system there contribute
more locks into the ecosystem to make it
easier for new folks to get started
right I believe we are at time so thank
you all for attending
[Applause]